what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we got ourselves an official trailer
for Ahsoka I heard John and I were featured
in the featurette which is cool I heard we
had a split second that's what I'm talking about
Star Wars so I'm talking about Kathleen Kennedy
everyone's hero John how are you uh so can't
wait for this G top that koi uh so can't yeah
ladies and gentlemen leave a like also wanted
to give a mention that Saturday July 22nd
the real rejects us are going to be having a
Comic-Con panel 1pm so if you're going to sdcc
please attend our panel come say hi take a photo
with John catch koi on his way out as he rushes
to his following panel leave a like uh and yeah
we'll be covering this show I can't wait to watch
it love me some Ahsoka Tano you're gonna be doing
a panel with Rosario Dawson aren't you that's
right that's right so it is relevant to have
you here tomorrow all right see what's going on
it's inevitable Must Destroy in order to
create all right rest in peace no Jedi
I love the red logo I started hearing whispers
of thrawn's return as heir to the Empire God
damn right damn what happens when we find thrawn
bad stuff such as you've
never dreamed this looks great
I've spent most of my life fighting Awards trying
to convince you to help me prevent another one
dude and I both know who could help you with this
stubborn as ever I bet your master
found you difficult at times Anakin
never got to finish my training away from him just
like I walked away from Sabine you
never made things easy for me master
as a Jedi sometimes you have to make the
decision no one else can wait hold on
what's up doing my mind racial nice haircut
as a Bridger animation in the background
I guess we have to do what's right regardless
of our person it's a close-up on the answer
version of the animation there was like
actual Rebels animation a little bit
if we don't stop throng everything oh
[__] wow close-up he looks cool no power
Anakin spoke highly of you
here to discuss my past we have a lot of work to
do once a rebel always a rebel goddamn
right oh the Mandalorian action there
aren't questioners are back
two episodes so premiere cool I love that
music wait a minute it's been a long time
since I've seen Star Wars Rebels um but there's
in the trailer the part that stood out to me the
most is when Sabine calls Ahsoka master so at
the end of rebels you know like a big part of
this is going to explore what have they been
up to since that ending of rebels right when
they were on the search for Ezra Bridger
and now if I recall correctly I remember
Sabine is she's Force sensitive and she had
some training with Kanan but she never like
completed trade in order to become a Jedi I've
heard rumors that maybe down the road should I
become a Jedi but it seems like they're setting
her up here in this series to eventually become
a Jedi and and for her to call her master meaning
she was being trained by Ahsoka to become a Jedi
that's pretty crazy some crazy [__] all right
that's like my one big question mark there because
that opens up a whole new can of worms but uh yeah
I'm loving everything we're seeing with Sabine I'm
loving everything that we've still barely got any
Ezra Bridger here and uh everything that we were
seeing with uh Mary Elizabeth uh Winstead as Hera
uh looks awesome too I think she's gonna deliver
a solid performance and uh yeah this is I mean
I'll save some general thoughts for for you boys
uh koi why don't you spout some general thoughts
uh Ray Stevenson is always such a force and to see
him like open this trailer and having you know
we recently lost him I'm really encapsulated by
being captivated by his presence and everything
so to see him as this I mean it looks like a Sith
Lord looks like someone like very powerful
and dominating I don't know the characters
I'm really excited to meet that world and it's a
new characters more comfortable than ever talking
about that one but this looks like uh you know
the scope of a movie which is what I like about
the Star Wars shows the trailers really allow
you to dive into a world and I love the movies
and and how powerful and impactful they feel this
feels like something you sit down and like watch
at a theater with your family so I loved the
scope of this I loved how the characters look
large and powerful and a lot of names I've heard
throughout Star Wars Lord getting to see them like
thrawn getting to see in live action getting to
see Mary Elizabeth Winstead's character I'm I'm
really excited to expand the Galaxy beyond the
Skywalkers yeah that's what I'm saying yeah yeah
Johnny no absolutely and I mean this had like a
quality to it where it certainly it feels at home
among all the other different shows and movies
and stuff but this does have its own sort of Sheen
about it that I don't know drew me in quite a bit
because it doesn't have the same kind of Dusty
grit as like a Mandalorian but it still looks like
it'll be very sprawling and it'll be like there's
something about like the daylight quality like
you're just seeing all this stuff like kind of in
the Stark light of day that I think also like you
know people talk about the volume and how these
shows are developing some sort of look but this
had like you said that very striking cinematic
quality it looked like yeah a dramatic kind of you
know from what I understand about Rebels there is
a certain amount of that real sort of harrowing
uh you know grasp for heroism and this looks
like it'll represent that struggle very well this
felt very tangible in a way that I think could up
the caliber for you know these shows in the Star
Wars Universe moving forward I'm very excited to
see thrawn who is certainly going to be our Thanos
for whatever that movie is that they're gonna be
making and I'm sure you heard about that movie at
least right that they're it's gonna be uh putting
all these shows together so that way we can get
some type of cinematic super exciting like that
is such a smart thing for Star Wars fans I think
it's really exciting smarts that means thrawn's
more than likely going to survive uh this season
uh but for thrawn to be brought to live action I'm
enjoying the presence of him and I think that for
those who aren't that familiar with him actually
I I read the there was a book that was based on I
think it is called heir to the Empire and I read
the comic adaptation of it that is on as on the
Marvel unlimited app it's a Marvel comic guys and
I read the Marvel comic a couple months ago where
you see how he got into the Empire and how he rose
through the ranks and you see just how like of a
cunning like genius he is and I think that's the
part of it where people are going to be the most
surprised by if they're not that familiar with
thrawn because as menacing as he is you teach us
how sophisticated uh intellectual artistic smart
and uh manipulative like there's these fascinating
qualities about the guy so as much as we just look
to see like these teases and looks and these
ominous little looming uh areas that you see
in the shots of him I feel like the performance
requires a lot than just look like a creep it's
gonna be something that I feel like will be
something very special uh so yeah man uh I've
I have a lot of faith in this Dave filoni didn't
do much work on Mandalorian season three upon
mistaken because he was too busy putting this
whole what I hear is like like a borderline
Masterpiece at least like people have seen it
really upset like it's pretty incredible so
I'm excited to see it guys what did you think
about the Ahsoka trailer leave your thoughts
down below thank you so much for being here
um leave a like and Hey listen to the patreon
Brian Perry Brian my dude you seem like the
kind of guy we could put our faith behind to
save us from the machinations of the Sith
and the dark side all right you got a nice
star wars-esque name which I think is perfect
you can't get a star war going without a good
iconic name Brian Perry four syllables like
Ahsoka Tano it's perfect my dude what color
lightsaber would you have how would you wield
the force and bring hope to the Galaxy that's
what I want to know that's what I want to see
because we are now your padawans and you got
all the midichlorians my dude your Force levels
are off the charts so we are at your service we
are without fear we are one with the force
and the forces with us but most of all we
are one with your pledge so keep it up buddy
and we'll see you next month thank you Brian